wo ist ein
[Musik]
ich glaube nicht dass ich an im sack ein
gericht aus baden württemberg ist hier
steht eine spezialität der stadt
oldenburg in oldenburg liegt in baden
württemberg also dachte ich du bist
nicht nur im falschen bundesland du bist
in der komplett falschen region
oldenburg liegt im nordwesten des
bundeslandes niedersachsen rupps
heiliger ich suche meinen vokabelheft
habe ich es zufällig liegen lassen ja im
linken schrank unter der theke super ich
brauche nämlich weil ich später meine b1
prüfung viel erfolg jahre hat sich
gestern gesucht was ich aber schon
geklärt
jan im sack was macht ihr hier
wir suchen klassische deutsche gerichte
mit total verrückten namen wie tote oma
wir erklären die herkunft des gerichts
und wie man es zubereitet und die videos
stellen wir dann ins internet
danke
danke also woher kommt kalter und kalter
und